this is how Spain's hoping to win the
war on the coronavirus police are among
the first to be tested but it's
hazardous work for these medical staff a
large number of those testing positive
are health workers in Madrid where an
ice rinks been turned into a makeshift
morgue
war horses arrived on Thursday the death
toll has risen to more than 4000
overtaking China and in Italy still
Europe's worst affected country the dead
have been temporarily stored in churches
before being sent for cremation by army
truck in a deserted European Parliament
chamber the Commission president urged
Europeans to show solidarity several EU
countries including Germany and France
have banned exports of protective gear
to avoid shortfalls at home ursula von
der Leyen warms the practice undermined
Europe's joint response to the crisis we
all share this responsibility none of us
can do it alone and certainly no member
state can handle this crisis on their
own and because in this crisis and in
our union more generally it is only by
helping each other that we can help
ourselves in Paris health workers are
conducting drive-through testing in the
streets Frances death toll rose by 28
percent on Thursday tracing the spread
of the virus is vital for controlling it
president macron is one of several world
leaders joining g20 talks remotely
hoping for a global approach to the
pandemic on the same conference call the
Russian President Vladimir Putin he
believes Russia can defeat the virus in
less than three months with tough
measures the country will suspend
international flights from Friday a
Moscow will close all shops except
pharmacies and grocery stores a day
later in the UK the British vacuum
cleaner maker Dyson has joined a growing
number of technology companies
developing ventilators this has worked
to convert a massive exhibition hall
into an emergency hospital
continues in East London laughing two
weeks
one British woman Starck account of
having the virus has been shared online
kerim honoring his 26 weeks pregnant
the British government promised to ramp
up testing by the end of the week with
hospitals in London told to expect a
continuous tsunami of patients
scientists are warning many countries in
Europe that the worst is yet to come
Nev Parker al Jazeera